ne va pas être violent mais on va rester
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite c'est les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 27 octobre 2020
en france le premier ministre juge de
nouvelles mesures indispensables pour
lutter contre l'épidémie
cet après midi jean castex a reçu les
principaux dirigeants politiques sur la
gravité de la crise sanitaire avant de
s'entretenir avec les partenaires
sociaux recond finement totale ou
partielle c'est emmanuel macron qui va
arbitrer les décisions demain matin lors
d'un conseil de défense le chef de
l'état et qui s'exprimera demain soir à
20h à la télévision est les français
sont donc suspendus aux futures
nouvelles annonces des manuels macron
face au co vie d'une telle situation de
crise qui plus est inédite
elle place le président en première
ligne ces décisions des conséquences sur
le quotidien des français depuis six
mois et pour quelques temps encore alors
à un an et demi de l'élection
présidentielle quel peut être l'impact
politique du coc vide pour emmanuel
macron peut-il en ressortir grandi ou
affaiblies ce sera l'édito d'alexis
poule à
[Musique]
total dans le viseur ce mercredi se
tiendra l'audience en appel de l'affairé
opposant deux associations françaises et
quatre ougandais zoo géant pétrolier
elle accuse la firme de ne pas prendre
en compte les impacts de ses activités
en ouganda et en tanzanie sur les
populations et l'environnement et soit
être faire appliquer le devoir de
vigilance
une étape importante pour une première
action en justice fondée sur la loi sur
le devoir de vigilance des
multinationales
[Musique]
emmanuel macron devrait annoncer ce
mercredi à 20h un durcissement des
mesures de restriction pour endiguer la
deuxième vague de l'épidémie de kovy de
19,1 premier conseil de défense a eu
lieu ce matin un deuxième doit se tenir
demain et en fin d'après midi jean
castex a reçu les chefs de partis et les
partenaires sociaux et parmi les
scénarios envisagés l'élargissement du
couvre-feu à 19h et où est un
confinement localiser et l'idée d'un
confinement le week-end serait également
envisagée mais la possibilité d'un
reconfirme en général est clairement sur
la table elle gérald darmanin à
elisabeth board ont prévenu de nouvelles
décisions vont devoir être prises il
faut s'attendre à des décisions
difficiles je ne sais pas quels seront
elles exactement la situation est grave
elle va nous amener rapidement à prendre
de nouvelles mesures et les
restaurateurs redoutaient un confinement
strict sept restaurateurs sur 10 en ile
de france aurait perdu au moins 50 % de
chiffre d'affaires selon la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie paris ile de
france depuis le début de la crise du
commis de 19
notre reporter jonathan en moa dab a été
alors rencontre déjà actuellement nous
on ferme à 8h30 ça veut dire on perd à
peu près la moitié de notre chiffre
d'affaires
et là si on va aller comme c'est prévu
de confinement et le week-end je ne sais
pas exactement mais ils ont parlé d'eux
de grands films les week-ends et le
couvre-feu à partir de 19 heures ça veut
dire pour nous c'est y est c'est fini
l'activité est mort là il tourné l'année
qu'on vient de passer j'ai plus leur
montrant que j'ai décidé de faire un
petit peu au jour le jour et de
m'adapter mais
et oui forcément ça sera ça sera une
année encore plus difficile si on vous
l'a terminé avec le resteront fermés
quoi on va pas on va pas pouvoir s'en
sortir parce que déjà c'est juste ce
qu'on fait le salon peut pas faire plus
10 15 couverts là sont à passer ce qu'on
fait ça suffit pas tu vas pour la
soumettre toutes les charges qu'on a
c'est impossible de travailler à mi
temps
elle sonne pour travailler à mi-temps et
tenir le coup pendant toutes sortes de
six mois terribles là je pas combien de
temps pour devenir le pire ça serait que
confirme plutôt à 19 ans en le soir ses
sous il ya fait nachi pratiquement donc
heureusement qu'on a là que la partie
tabac à côté pour avoir un peu de
trésorerie sinon c'est un peu compliqué
ouais ben on risque des grosses pertes
de chiffres d'affaires et on risque
d'être longuement d'été puis on va vers
une fermeture administrative
alors que le gouvernement s'apprête à
annoncer de nouvelles mesures sanitaires
pour faire face à la pandémie à
l'épidémie de kobe de 19
l'inquiétude monte on remarque depuis
plusieurs mois le gouvernement a annoncé
et tout et son contraire dans ses
déclarations et kirill quotidien voilà
plus de six mois que nous vivons avec le
co vide
bien que faible la mortalité du virus
est bien réelle beaucoup de personnes
contaminées guérisse mais certaines
ressemblent des complications jusqu'à
plusieurs mois après leur guérison
les français semblent avoir acquis les
gestes barrières nécessaires pour
limiter la propagation de l'épidémie il
n'y a qu'à voir dans la rue tout le
monde porte un masque les gens ne se
font plus la bise évite les contacts
serré et prolongée même si ce n'est pas
toujours évident mais ce qui agace les
français c'est la manière dont le
gouvernement gère la crise en effet il
ne leur aura décidément rien épargné en
termes d' incohérences dans le discours
officiel
répétant tout et son contraire en
permanence
on n'est pas dans une deuxième vague du
coronavirus on est dans la poursuite
d'une épidémie a plus ou moins bas bruit
en fonction des pays et des villes
concernées la réalité de la deuxième
vague et la chapelle de façon
extrêmement clair à ce que nous nous
mobilisions toutes et tous pour faire
face à cette deuxième vague
il ne peut plus avoir de relâchement
personne n'a besoin de porter un masque
si un médecin ne vous demande pas
d'emporter un et vous savez quoi
moi je ne sais pas utiliser un masque je
pourrais dire je suis ministre je me
mets un masque mais en fait je ne sais
pas l'utiliser parce que l'utilisation
d'un masque ce sont des gestes
techniques précis le port du masque
notamment lorsqu il y à une
concentration de personnes moi je le
recommande pour ce qui est du couvre feu
le président de la république nous
explique que ce dernier serait légitime
et par le fait que la sphère privée
serait le premier vecteur de
contamination
en réalité on constate assez vite que
les écoles les universités les
entreprises sont tout aussi dangereuse
sauf que ça n'arrange pas vraiment le
gouvernement parce que cela aurait un
impact plus grand sur l'économie on
pourrait le comprendre
sauf que ce n'est pas dit comme ça il y
assez longues phrases et ses
approximations
le gouvernement est tellement prudent
dans sa manière d'annoncer des mesures
que les français se sentent peu à peu
baladé de gauche à droite
notre objectif ça doit être de réduire
les contacts privés qui sont les
contacts les plus dangereux c'est à dire
les moments un peu de relâchement on va
se retrouver avec des gens qui ne sont
pas dans notre cellule familiale et où
on va ce qui est souvent des moments de
convivialité il faut bien dire
c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2020 on fera
tout pour nos jeunes
mais c'est normal quand on est jeune on
fait la fête on a des amis et donc je ne
culpabilise ray personne mais je
voudrais qu'on prenne pendant quelques
semaines et quelques mois que je ne leur
demande pas d'avoir moins d'amis on va
devoir faire un peu d'effort c'est à
dire se voir moins nombreux en même
temps en attendant les français doivent
faire face à des mesures qui se font de
plus en plus restrictives les bars et
les cafés ferment le couvre-feu 7 ans et
ce pourrait désormais que la france
doive subir un nouveau confinement
pourtant selon l' oms cette mesure est à
prendre
en dernier recours les mesures de
distanciation physique et les
restrictions à la liberté de circulation
à grande échelle
souvent appelé confinement peuvent
ralentir la transmission de lakovic 19
en limitant les contacts entre les
personnes cependant ces mesures peuvent
avoir des conséquences délétères graves
sur les individus les communautés les
sociétés car elle entraîne un arrêt
quasi total de la vie sociale et
économique
ces mesures affectent de manière
disproportionnée les groupes défavorisés
le ms a bon espoir que les pays
appliqueront des interventions ciblées
là où cela sera nécessaire et le moment
voulu
en se fondant sur la situation locale la
situation de la france est elle si grave
les français ont ils droit à un
confinement total le gouvernement doit
annoncer de nouvelles mesures à l'issue
d'un second conseil de défense
et on le disait emmanuel macron va
s'exprimer demain à 20 heures à la
télévision une prise de parole qui
augure de mesure encore plus restrictive
face au co vide est les français se
préparent à ces mesures difficiles comme
l'a dit gérald darmanin à mézidon il
atteint les limites de l'acceptabilité
alors que dans d'autres pays la colère
est grandissante on en parle tout de
suite avec nos invités place à notre
décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
francis palombie président de la
confédération nationale des commerçants
de france bonsoir bonsoir à vos côtés et
christophe prudhomme urgentiste au samu
de bobigny et porte parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france bonsoir alors les messieurs
les alertes 1 venant des médecins ou du
secteur et hospitaliers se multiplient
ces dernières heures christophe
prudhomme vous qui êtes urgentiste on
est dans une situation déjà très
critique ou est-ce qu'on anticipe une
situation qui pourrait devenir critique
concernant les mesures à prendre selon
nos confrères d'europe 1 re confinement
est clairement sur la table
alors ce soir quelle est la situation et
pour quel scénario vous optez que la
situation est tendue dans les hôpitaux
mais cette situation est due à la
préparation par le gouvernement de
l'hôpital aujourd'hui nous avons 2800
balade en réanimation
ce qui n'est pas un chiffre
catastrophique
en soi c'est catastrophique parce que
nous avons trop peu l'île réanimation
rien n'a été fait à l'issue de la
première vague nous sommes montés à 7300
malades et aujourd'hui c'est une crise
de l'hôpital
il n'ya pas réellement de crise
sanitaire majeure
le nombre de morts est important mais il
explose pas donc le problème avec ce
gouvernement c'est que il manie les
mesures en se focalisant uniquement sur
la bombe atomique
quand on est en galère il faut utiliser
toutes les armes à sa disposition une
seule larme atomique qu'elle re
confinement ça les effets collatéraux
comme le souligne la déclaration l'om
est ce que vous venez de présenter donc
aujourd'hui j'aimerais bien qu'on parle
oui effectivement de mesures de
protection des populations les plus à
risque
mais qu'on parle aussi des d'autres
moyens pour éviter leur confinement qui
se serait une catastrophe
c'est à dire pourquoi cette incurie sur
les tests pourquoi cette situation de
l'hôpital avec un manque de moyens
manque de lits de réanimation
voilà donc moi je ne suis pas favorable
à un recrutement parce que vous savez
les conséquences sanitaires durant
confinement risque d'être plus grave
pour la majorité de la population que ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui avec la chorale
avis russie alors on entend la colère du
médecin la colère des hospitaliers en
général depuis des semaines des mois
voire des années maintenant
francis pas l'en but on a aussi entendu
dans jour noir l'inquiétude grande
inquiétude grande colère aussi des
restaurateurs notamment alors on ne
connaît pas les mesures qui vont être
annoncées en tout cas on est prévenu
elles vont être durs la fin de l'année
est une période vitale pour les
commerçants comment est ce que vous êtes
associé aux décisions qui vont être
prises en tant que président de la
confédération des commerçants on vous a
consulté pour l'instant n'ont
véritablement puisque depuis plusieurs
jours depuis plusieurs heures
les bruits circulent de plus en plus et
on ne sait pas vraiment à quelle sauce
on va être mangé donc nous sommes très
très inquiet je suis appelé constamment
par les commerçants les fédérations
professionnelles
moi je suis clair et net je renforce le
propos de ceux de monsieur le docteur
non il ne faut par confiner
psychologiquement
économiquement ça ne peut pas être nous
avons vécu le premier confinement le
déconfinement c'est vrai que c'est
difficile sur un plan économique mais
quand même on ressent que la population
est relativement discipline et on a tous
notre masque on prend des mesures
d'hygiène nécessaires et on avait
l'impression jusqu'à ces derniers jours
que nous commencions à vivre avec le
confinement
alors il ya un choix ou on s'arrête de
vivre où on vit avec le confinement et
moi je choisi la deuxième solution comme
la plupart des citoyens et des français
donc fermer à nouveau les magasins à
quelques semaines de noël
c'est une hérésie c'est même impensable
et j'espère que même s'il y a des
mesures renforcées de confinement je
peux bien comprendre la position des
médecins que vous représentez monsieur
ce soir et d'autres avez-vous je veux
bien comprendre qu'il faille durcir
renforcer contrôler davantage mais
surtout ne pas re confinés sur un plan
économique c'est dramatique
et est-ce que le gouvernement va pouvoir
continuer à soutenir les entreprises
moi je porte les très petites
entreprises celles qui ont moins de 11
salariés pardon et ses entreprises
après un premier confinement elles sont
déjà affectés malgré les aides de l'état
qui ont quand même qu'ils sont
intervenus il faut le reconnaître
et bien c'est une ce serait une
catastrophe d'euros confiné et en plus
ça va donner une partie belle encore
plus forte au grand entrepôt numérique
aux grands
au grand pure players comme amazon ou
alibaba qui commence à faire des
promotions actuellement acheté sur
amazon vous jouez vous paierez en quatre
fois sans frais comment voulez vous que
la distribution classique la
distribution de terrain la distribution
physique puisse résister à cela mais
nous demandons au gouvernement de
prendre des mesures claires et nettes
dans d'empêcher actuellement les grandes
player les pure players de faire des
promotions des black friday
alors que la france est en désarroi sur
le plan économique et sur le plan
sanitaire alors justement le
gouvernement jean castex à a rencontré
il ya quelques instants
certains chefs de partis et on va en
écouter certains d'entre eux ils ont
fait part de leur agacement face aux
réponses floues du gouvernement écoute
et nous avions aimé connaître et c'est
ce que j'ai demandé au ministre d'avoir
les idées différentes options étaient
sur la table sur quoi travaille et il et
quels sont les impacts à la fois
économiques socio sanitaire qui
permettent de prendre une décision
hélas ça n'a pas été possible je le
regrette parce que sur un sujet comme
celui là le problème n'est pas de cacher
la copie le problème n'est pas non plus
être dans la polémique comme à nantes
mais de faire en sorte que les
françaises et les français aient le
sentiment que ceux qui les gouvernent ou
que ceux qui sont appelés à les
gouverner demain sont en mesure de
répondre à ce qui est aujourd'hui une
pandémie pour laquelle tout semble
indiquer que nous avons perdu le
contrôle le premier ministre nous fait
venir et ne nous présente aucun scénario
des paroles floues vague confinement pas
confinement couvre-feu améliorer
accentuée c'est une débâcle
gouvernementales et on peut pas nous
demander de prendre parti sur des
solutions qu'on nous présente pas ça
j'avoue je ne comprends pas j'ai répété
ce que j'ai répété à chaque réunion
depuis le 27 février lits de réanimation
test contrôles aux frontières des
mesures précises sur les personnes
vulnérables
mais en vérité il ne nous consulte que
lorsqu'elle feu à la maison et qu'ils
sont confrontés au confinement
christophe prudhomme on vient entendant
colligées fort du parti socialiste
nicolas dupont aignan ensuite du parti
debout la france
ils pointent tous les deux finalement un
certain flou du gouvernement un manque
de capes que ce manque de cap vous le
percevez aussi aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
ah oui tout à fait et quand monsieur le
ministre de la santé dit que l'hôpital
est prêt écoutez j'étais en contact tout
à l'heure avec des collègues nous a
fallu nous fait une réunion des
urgentistes un collègue de l'hôpital
d'orthez plus de gants disponibles plus
de gants dans l'essonne également des
tensions sur les gants donc rien n'a été
fait l'épidémie nous a laissé quatre
mois de répit et rien n'a été fait et
aujourd'hui on attend la parole de dieu
le président de la république demain on
aimerait bien quand même que on nous
écoute nous les professionnels de
terrain depuis plusieurs semaines nous
demandons que l'on utilise les tests
rapides en particulier pour les
personnels qui sont en contact avec les
personnes fragiles dans les ehpad pour
l'aide à domicile ça c'est très
important rien n'a été fait dans ce
domaine pour l'hôpital c'est une
catastrophe en termes de moyens donc
aujourd'hui il faut être conscient que
va falloir s'occuper de réellement isolé
dans de bonnes conditions
les personnels contagieuse protéger les
plus faibles
mais vous savez la santé a trois
composantes le physique le psychologique
et social 1re confinement généraliser ce
serait psychologiquement et socialement
pour la population et là c'est le
médecin qui parle ça serait
catastrophique
je vous dis le confinement c'est la
bombe atomique et la bombe atomique
eh bien ça laisse des traces ça laisse
des traces indélébiles et très prolongée
donc j'aimerais bien que le gouvernement
arrête de faire des réunions qui ne
servent à rien nous aussi nous sommes
réunis dans des réunions où on a aucune
discussion possible
on peut pas discuter des différentes
options pour choisir collectivement
n'est piste que l'on doit prendre pour
les semaines qui viennent là qu'est ce
que vous voulez depuis une semaine on
nous parlera en confinement et on attend
la parole de l'oracle de dieu là à
l'elysée demain soir écoutez moi je
comprends
là les représentants des partis
politiques et puis il faut savoir aussi
que il va falloir quand même qu'à un
moment donné
eh bien on écoute les professionnels de
terrain mes collègues de ville là où on
était obligé de se manifester ont de
nouveau avoir des masques vont pouvoir
travailler
si la ville n'a pas les moyens de
travailler pour éviter l'engorgement de
l'hôpital et bien effectivement on sera
dans une crise encore plus grave
on n'a rien appris on a l'impression que
ce gouvernement n'a rien appris de
l'épisode du printemps et que
aujourd'hui
eh bien il court de nouveau après
l'épidémie et ça c'est catastrophique et
je peux vous dire que les professionnels
de santé sont épuisés sont en colère
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital nous ne sommes
pas plus nombreux qu'au début d'année
que de nouveaux
nous sommes en difficulté pour ouvrir
des lits parce qu'il n'y a pas assez de
personnel disponible et quand on
explique qu'il serait bien de recruter
immédiatement du personnel non qualifié
vous savez des gens qu'on appelle les
agents de service hospitalier qui
pourrait nous aider pour faire les lits
porter les robes pas à brocarder ont
mené l'étude des examens en laboratoire
et bien on ne nous répond pas et on
utilise du personnel qualifié et
soignants pour faire toutes ces tâches à
l'hôpital ils sont déjà épuisées dont
qui arrive à un moment donné eh bien il
serait bon que le ministre l'a la santé
plutôt que nous vanter le fait que
l'hôpital a tenu tiendra encore on
remercie les soignants qu'on nous écoute
et que ce ne soit pas que de la
communication avec un seul un seul une
seule parole qui paraît valide celle du
président de la république
et puis arrêtons les réunions les avis
divers et variés les agences régionales
de santé de la haute autorité de santé
de l'académie de médecine
en fait tous ces gens qui nous explique
comment il faut travailler sur le
terrain selon nous que nous demande un
nouveau gouvernement jeudi à monsieur
virant monsieur virant pourquoi
n'abondent plus de gants aujourd'hui
disponible dans les hôpitaux qu'avez
vous fait on nous livrait des gants
voilà vous voyez c'est très basique
j'aimerais bien que le que le
gouvernement plutôt que de faire des
grandes déclarations répondre à ces
demandes très précises des soignants
aujourd'hui francis palombes y est la
colère à ce qu'elle peut aussi explosé
aujourd'hui chez les petits commerçants
vous vous représenter ce soir sur notre
antenne
est-ce qu'ils vont accepter aujourd'hui
finalement à nouveau confinement pour
leurs magasins écoutez j'en doute
véritablement parce que a constaté les
réactions que nous vivons actuellement
bon nous ne sommes pas le secteur
sanitaire santé comme le médecin
urgentiste qui lui a des positions très
très bien expliqué à ce soir c'est vrai
pas toujours très rassurante pour le
citoyen que je représente et d'autres je
suis davantage sur le secteur économique
mais par rapport au secteur économique
justement les très petites entreprises
me dise monsieur palombie qu'est ce que
je fais parce que depuis le mois de
septembre
comme l'activité avait recommencé il
faut le dire sauf malheureusement pour
mes fédération de des bars des
restaurants des hôtels qui eux sont
restés l'événementiel qui sont restés
sous un régime très restrictif et qui
sont très affectés un vent de reprise
s'était affirmée et maintenant leur dire
à nouveau et bien écouter parce que là
actuellement le chiffre d'affaires est
en berne
il ya quand même parfois des réactions
un peu anxiogène et qui surviennent sur
les médias de la part du gouvernement
dans quelques cas nous avons toujours
demandé au gouvernement de ne surtout
pas se montrer ambitieux gêne en
permanence parce que ça affecte le moral
des gens des troupes des commerçants et
des soignants de tout le monde donc nous
on reste sur une position de grande
inquiétude et le gouvernement sid
aventure on était dans l'obligation
administrative de fermer j'espère
j'espère que les mesures économiques de
soutien aux entreprises et notamment les
plus faibles que je représente les plus
petites seront immédiates et au niveau
de la tante de ces commerçants ce pour
les soutenir sinon malheureusement ces
commerçants vont faire faillite et c'est
parce que j'ai voulu
alors c'est vrai que je suis pas sur le
même registre que le médical
le gouvernement de la france
économiquement a fait des efforts a
soutenu l'activité
mais est-ce que elle va être soutenue à
nouveau on l'espère mais tant qu'on n'a
pas vu on ne peut pas en parler donc et
puis nous sommes affectés nous sommes
dans un déséquilibre de concurrence
pardonnez moi de revenir sur le sujet de
la concurrence qui devient dans les
circonstances actuelles déloyale de la
part des des grands entrepôts numérique
comme amazon et alibaba monfils le
consommateur ne vous en faites pas
comment qui vont profiter du confinement
laurent vide qui profitent de la
situation qui ont profité les grandes
surfaces sont restées ouvertes alors
nous demanderons bien sûr que les
grandes surfaces
au cas où et bien ne puisse se vendre
que de l'alimentaire parce que c'est un
c'est un bien de consommation
incontournable mais à ce moment là si
nos commerçants sont dans l'obligation
de fermer
nous demanderons une forme d'équité dans
le domaine du commerce
c'est et on demandera à ce que le
gouvernement demande des efforts
financiers pour la collectivité en
termes solidaire de la part des grands
entrepôts numérique
également il faut que ça soit juste et
équitable
la situation christophe prudhomme on a
entendu certains de vos confrères dire
une réanimation rater derrière c'est la
mort donc demandé plus d'efforts en
jambe à l'économie finalement elle peut
s'arrêter mais elle peut repartir pas
une mauvaise réanimation qu'est ce que
vous en pensez ce que vous voulez
rejoignez pour conclure en quelques mots
je ne les rejoins pas et il faut qu'il
ya un équilibre
il faut qu'on se donne les moyens pour
accueillir les malades à l'hôpital mais
écoutez nous avons aujourd'hui 2008 s'en
va là dans l'animation il n'avait 7003
au pic de la crise au mois d'avril on
devrait être en capacité de pouvoir
gérer ces malades
il faut qu'on s'en donne les moyens les
effets du
d'un certain nombre de mesures ciblées
sur les populations les plus fragiles il
faut savoir que 90 % des morts ont plus
de 60 ans donc pour le reste de la
population bien sûr il ya quelques
jeunes en réanimation mais avec une
mortalité qui est relativement faible
nous sommes pas face à un virus hyper
violent et juste pour terminer pour
montrer l'incurie du gouvernement là
pour protéger ces personnes il faudra
les vaccins contre la grippe
nous sommes en rupture de vaccins contre
la grippe parce que le gouvernement au
mois d'avril mais n'a pas commandé
auprès les industriels les vaccins en
nombre suffisant que font les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus de vaccins contre la
grippe dont un certain nombre de
pharmacies et une partie de la
population fragile aj ne pas pouvoir se
faire vacciner
du fait de la préparation dans la
préparation du gouvernement et d'une
attitude des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui est proprement
scandaleuse de ne pas avoir produit plus
de vaccins et qu'on soit en rupture
aujourd'hui c'est quand même
catastrophique dont vous voyez ne parler
que lui que d'une éventuelle reconfirme
ans celle de ne pas parler de ses vrais
problèmes qui sont les vrais problèmes
de santé publique et qui ne donne pas
les moyens de lutter réellement contre
l'épidémie
merci à tous les deux merci à vous
christophe prudhomme urgentiste au samu
de hausse amis de bobigny porte parole
de l'association des médecins
urgentistes de france merci avoue
francis palombie président de la
confédération des commerçants et puis
j'ajoute pour clore cette discussion
cette déclaration du porte parole du
gouvernement il va falloir prendre des
mesures face à une hausse exponentielle
de l'épidémie restez avec nous sur rt
france dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur les éventuelles
répercussions politiques
cette fois de la crise du coronavirus
pour emmanuel macron dans notre édito
avec alexis poulin et puis nous
parlerons de total ce mercredi se
tiendra l'audience en appel de l'affairé
opposant deux associations françaises et
quatre ougandais au géant pétrolier avec
un enjeu la loi sur le devoir de
vigilance des multinationales a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
dryden ou de la trump a le programme le
plus à même de redresser le pays quand
vous dites à un américain qui va être
taxés plus ils voient rouge
ils pencheront plus tôt pour ceux qui
leur chante une jolie chanson comme quoi
les impôts n'augmenteront pas aux
contours du programme de donald trump
sont quand même assez floue on pour
autant c'est vraiment sur la piste que
les secteurs sg bonbons à la veille du
grand film le taux de chômage est tombé
à 3,5 pourtant qu'à tout chômage de
plein emploi je peux vous dire une chose
c'est que le plein emploi
juste avant le coc vide c'était une
blague votre avis sur ce plan de relance
déjà il faut dire rien on est en train
de raser gratis
au bout du compte une facture à régler
baden il y sera sans doute probablement
aussi protectionniste est aussi agressif
sur le plan mondial
ce train
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent elles
en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview fresnoy à taken 2
[Musique]
ouah
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française est la crise sanitaire place
le président en première ligne et ses
décisions des conséquences sur le
quotidien des français depuis six mois
et pour quelques temps encore avec
qu'elles soient humaines économiques ou
sociales à la alors à un an et demi de
l'élection présidentielle
quel peut être l'impact politique du
coït pour emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état peut-il en ressortir grandi ou au
contraire affaibli on va en parler tout
de suite avec l'éditorialiste
alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito avec six poulains bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
second conseil de défense demain matin
leur confinement est sur toutes les
lèvres
l exécutif consulte les chefs de partis
les partenaires sociaux emmanuel macron
tranches d'ici 24 heures quel est le
risque politique d'annoncés 1re
confinement
le risque politique est grand c'est un
outil à double tranchant on voit bien
dans cette gestion de la crise sanitaire
que les décisions impopulaires qui
limite les libertés s'accumulent donc
peut-être deux choses la première c'est
pour emmanuel macron de montrer qu'il
est encore aux commandes qu'il n'a pas
totalement tout lâcher face à ce virus
qui semble hors de contrôle et que en
tant que chef de l'état il prend ses
responsabilités et que donc il va devoir
annoncer des mesures difficiles alors le
terrain était préparée par ses
lieutenants vous avez eu gérald darmanin
elisabeth bornes gabriela talent tout le
gouvernement quasiment aujourd'hui qui
s'est succédé au micro pour expliquer
que attention des mesures difficiles
vont devoir être je choisis par le chef
de l'état donc il est un peu préservé
donc se positionner en chef et reprendre
la main sur cette épidémie qui semble
totalement hors de contrôle
le problème c'est que si c'est pour
annoncer évidemment des mesures plus
dures l'imitatrice de liberté encore une
fois ils risquent de chuter de continuer
sa dégringolade dans les sondages il
s'était stabilisé autour de 36%
aujourd'hui les gens se demandent quelle
va être
quelles vont être les annonces et là
l'exécutif joue gros évidemment dans ces
annonces demain pour les faire passer à
la population on a vu en italie les
italiens en ont marre des mesures
liberticides ils sont dans la rue encore
ce soir à rome il était à milan à turin
ça ne passe plus il se pourrait que les
français et aussi ce ras-le-bol de ces
mesures qu'ils ne comprennent pas alors
au lieu dit attention c'est hautement
volatile on le disait emmanuel macron va
parler demain à 20h alors à quoi
s'attendre plutôt confinement nationale
re confinement locale qu'est ce qui
coûte politiquement plus cher alors tout
va coûter cher et pour l'économie et
pour l'image d'emmanuel macron et pour
le pays en général et pour le moral des
français sur la table aujourd'hui
lors des différentes rencontres qu'a pu
avoir jean castex avec les chefs de
partis les idées sont soit d'allonger la
durée du couvre-feu de le faire à partir
de 19h sur tout l'ensemble du territoire
soit un confinement pas alors ce serait
pas un confinement comme en mars
comme on a connu un confinement total
mais un confinement à partir du week end
ou seulement certains seraient autorisés
à sortir pour aller travailler ou les
écoles resteraient ouvertes mais où
quand même une grande partie de la
population se retrouverait à nouveau
confiné une fois encore reste la
lisibilité de ces mesures la
compréhension et l'impact qu'elles
peuvent avoir sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
parce que tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est dans la projection de ce
que pourrait être la courbe de ce corps
d'un virus de gens qui arriverait dans
les services d'urgence aujourd'hui c'est
de la moitié des lits
en réanimation qui sont occupés et la
peur c'est que chaque semaine le virus
soit exponentielle de 30% et qu'on
arrive très vite
au delà des capacités c'est terrible de
gérer cette pénurie au en haut du pic au
mois de mars on avait réussi à ouvrir
plus de quinze mille lits de réanimation
difficilement avec du temps peut-être
qu'il y aura des annonces sanitaire au
delà des annonces qui limite les
libertés parce que c'est pas uniquement
comme ça qu'on peut lutter contre ce
virus et qu'on peut rétablir la
confiance avec les français parce
qu'aujourd'hui je crois que beaucoup de
concitoyens n'ont plus aucune confiance
dans la parole du chef de l'état et de
l'exécutif dans la gestion de cette
crise depuis le mois de mars a été
calamiteuse justement alexis le
gouvernement n'at-il pas tiré les leçons
de la première crise clairement pas
regarder ce qu'il s'est passé
lorsqu agnès buzyn quitte son poste à la
santé elle annonce que le pire est
devant nous rien n'a été vraiment prévu
à l'époque il n'y avait pas de masque
donc les masques étaient inutiles dans
la doctrine proposée par le gouvernement
ils s'en défendent maintenant
aujourd'hui devant les commissions
d'enquêté à l'assemblée nationale
ensuite il y a eu des tests le fiasco
des tests très mal faits difficilement
fait les passoires qu'on était les
aéroports et les frontières on a on n'a
pas fermé les frontières là où il aurait
dû faire il aurait fallu fermer les
frontières à l'époque donc des erreurs
en cascade des temps de retard à
l'allumage systématique et un mur au
mois de mars qu'il a fallu gérer avec ce
grand confinement qui a mis l'économie
par terre geoffroy roux de bézieux
patron du medef le rappelait lundi s'il
fallait reconfirmer aujourd'hui les
entreprises n'ont plus la même
trésorerie qu'au mois de mars
l'économie n'est plus du tout dans le
même état et ce serait une catastrophe
pour l'économie française qui ne s'en
remettrait pas cette fois ci même si
elle n'en sait pas vraiment remis du
premier confinement et puis il y a eu
toutes les annonces pendant cet été jean
michel blanquer air qui disait que tout
était prêt ne vous inquiétez pas
emmanuel macron qui le 14 juillet
annonce que si jamais une deuxième vague
arrive tout elle tout est mis en place
dans les territoires les stocks sont
prêts et il n'y aura pas du tout le même
cafouillage qu'au mois de mars
et bien voilà où nous en sommes même
cafouillage voire pire on en est encore
à demander à des à des couturiers et
couturières de faire des sur blues on
manque de matériel médical comme au mois
de mars
les tests on en a mais la fiabilité
reste à voir et est surtout là où il
aurait fallu pérenniser les lits de
réanimation parce que le virus est là
pour longtemps
et bien non on a refermé délit on a
continué les rs ont continué lors de
leur travail de sape de fermetures de
lits d'hôpital de flux et aujourd'hui on
se retrouve avec 5000 lits de
réanimation peut-être même un peu moins
qu'au mois de mars et il va falloir
demander d'ouvrir en urgence de nouveaux
lits de réanimation alors que même les
soignants eux sont en berne at cette
fois ci et ne comprennent plus rien en
fait c'est une feuille totale du système
à la fois avec un exécutif qui est dans
une gestion erratique de cette crise au
coup par coup sans stratégie globale et
puis vous avez tout ce système les ars
l'administration qui ne gère plus rien
qui gère finalement la crise la pénurie
sans avoir les moyens de prendre le
temps et est de mettre en place les
mesures nécessaires donc on est dans une
folie nationale et on va annoncer demain
et malal macron va annoncer des mesures
encore liberticide
sans plus pour lutter contre ce virus
alors qu'on aurait pu quand même cet été
et depuis le mois de mars préparer
davantage la réponse à cette crise
sanitaire et du coup aujourd'hui
l'avenir de l'exécutif est utile en jeu
oui alors surtout la tête de jean castex
je pense ça va être très difficile pour
lui de se maintenir en position surtout
dans l'optique de 2022 c'est un fusible
évident jean castex
il était celui qui a géré le
déconfinement qui devenu une déconfiture
il est premier ministre les mesures
qu'il annonce et qu'il a essayé de
prendre avec le gouvernement ont été une
catastrophe depuis le mois de septembre
donc pour lui la position extrêmement
difficile et puis dans les sondages il a
il est très très bas aujourd'hui il n'a
jamais vraiment imprimé dans la
population française
quant à emmanuel macron et bien il a
connu des hauts et des bas dans les
sondages aujourd'hui il tourne autour de
36% de gens satisfaits de son action
c'est très peu pour un président de la
république c'est toujours un peu plus
que françois hollande à une certaine
époque un peu plus que lui aussi
rappelez-vous en décembre 2018 au pic de
la manifestation des gilets jaunes il
était à 23 % seulement de gens
satisfaits son action donc il peine il
était à la peine ça va être extrêmement
compliqué pour lui et surtout on a
l'impression qu'il ne sait pas ce qu'il
fait est que sa parole n'a plus de
valeur entre la promesse faite au 14
juillet que tout serait prêt pour la
seconde vague est ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on ne peut
pas faire confiance à emmanuel macron et
que quoi qu'il annonce demain les
français vont le regarder de manière
très circonspecte en se disant bon c'est
encore de la com
on va voir il ya une résignation dans le
pays aujourd'hui je crois que tout le
monde essaye de faire du mieux qu'il
peut pour lutter contre ce virus mais
n'attend pas grand chose finalement de
l'exécutif a par un exercice de
communication qui tourne à vide
merci beaucoup alexis poulain c'était
notre rubrique l'édito est dans
l'actualité également cette dernière
semaine d'auditions des accusés des
attentats de janvier 2015
parmi eux ali riza peau la seule des
onze accusés
poursuivi pour complicité des
assassinats terroristes une audition
débuté hier et qui se poursuit donc
aujourd'hui les précisions depuis le
tribunal de paris de notre reporter
katia pétanque vient entre hier et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a appris c'est que
l'accusé nie formellement tout ce qui
lui est reproché il conteste pied à pied
chaque élément
en fait il n'y a pas de révélation juste
des contradictions avec tout ce qu'on
peut lui reprocher c'est un bras de fer
qui s'est établi à avec les avocats des
parties civiles depuis un moment il nie
avoir été le bras droit et la
conversation est très animé mais peu
d'éléments en ressorte alors déjà il n'y
a que des indices un pas de preuve
formelle d'une complicité dali paulette
pad adn sur les armes pad adn sur les
voitures utilisées par exemple et le
l'accusé à l'ipo là tu connais son
dossier sur le bout des doigts alors
c'est pourquoi il peut tout contester il
contredit toutes les versions des
accusés qui pourraient l'incriminé
surtout celles qui vont changer au cours
du temps de la parade autres accusés et
il persiste et signe dans sa version il
avait une dette envers amedi coulibaly
pour cela il a vendu une voiture et
point barre et en revanche tout ce qui
peut paraître louche dans le dossier des
questions d'armes des questions et
éventuellement de drogue est lié selon
lui à d'autres affaires et donc pas le
terrorisme par exemple il souhaitait
braquer une banque c'est pourquoi il
aurait fait une liste d'armes donc en
tout cas comme à l'ipo latin il faut
dire que les autres accusés nie
également les faits qui leur sont
reprochés
c'est ce qu'on a vu tout au long de ce
procès c'est pourquoi il est très
difficile d'établir les responsabilités
des uns et des autres encore à ce jour
le groupe pétrolier total dans la
tourmente avec cette audience demain de
la cour d'appel de versailles plusieurs
ong ont exprimé leur inquiétude
concernant deux projets de la firme en
tanzanie en ouganda
elles sont françaises et ougandaises et
accusent le géant pétrolier de ne pas
prendre en compte les impacts de ses
activités sur les populations et
l'environnement et souhaite faire
appliquer le devoir de vigilance estelle
farges un cauchemar nommé total c'est le
nom d'un rapport publié le 20 octobre
dernier par les ong survie
et les années de la terre dans ce
document les associations pointent du
doigt deux projets de la firme total
le premier le projectile en ga en
ouganda il inclut le forage et
l'exploitation de 400 puits dont 132 se
trouverait selon le rapport dans un parc
naturel protégé du pays
le second l'icop un projet de
construction d'un gigantesque oléoduc de
pétrole brut le plus long pape line
chauffer au monde qui traverserait
l'ouganda et la tanzanie
problème selon une enquête menée par les
deux ong à l'origine du rapport ces deux
projets entraînerait des déplacements
massifs de population et l'accaparement
de leurs terres selon les témoignages
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
sont privées de leurs terres avant même
d'avoir reçu la moindre compensation
sont les témoignages collectés
cela fait plus de deux ans qu'elle se
retrouve donc sans aucun moyen de
subsistance entraînant des situations de
famine et de déscolarisation de
nombreuses personnes dénoncent avoir
subi des pressions et intimidations pour
signer les formulaires de cession de
leurs terres et disent ne pas savoir
quand ni parfois même combien elles vont
être indemnisés pour racheter de
nouvelles terres et culture outre la
violation des droits humains les ong
pointent aussi du doigt les dommages
irréversibles de ces deux projets sur
l'environnement le projet thierry gamme
est donc en danger la biodiversité du
parc des moeurs qui sonne falls les
cours d'eau dont les communautés
dépendent pour leur quotidien le lac
albert qui contient environ 30% des
pêcheries en ouganda ainsi que les sols
dont les paysans dépendent pour
l'agriculture et l'air qu'il respire
l'oléoduc menace donc l'accès à l'eau et
à la nourriture deux millions de
personnes dans la région
il traversera des forêts des zones
humides et des mangroves participants la
déforestation à la destruction de la
biodiversité et des moyens de
subsistance des communautés locales
ainsi qu'au réchauffement climatique
total s'est défendu face à ces
accusations la firme indique notamment
que ces deux projets ont été conçus dans
le souci de minimes
les impacts sur les communautés locales
le plan de vigilance de total identifie
clairement les risques que pour les
droits de l'homme les libertés
fondamentales la santé et la sécurité
des personnes et l'environnement qui
pourraient résulter de nos activités
total est pleinement conscient des
impacts potentiels sur les communautés
locales
un dialogue transparent permanent
garantie que toutes les préoccupations
exprimées sont traités de manière
appropriée
l'année dernière les ong les années de
la terre et survie notamment porte la
faire devant les tribunaux elle souhaite
que total applique son devoir de
vigilance souvenez-vous ce texte de loi
a été introduit à l'assemblée nationale
juste après le drame durana plaza au
bangladesh elle oblige les entreprises
françaises à mettre en place des plans
de vigilance pour prévenir les atteintes
aux droits humains ou à l'environnement
le tribunal judiciaire de nanterre s'est
déclaré incompétent pour statuer sur ce
cas et à renvoyer le dossier vers le
tribunal de commerce ce que souhaitait
total les ong ont fait appel l'audience
se tiendra le 28 octobre
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
marine calme est présidente de
l'association wild rigole marine calmet
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors l'audience et demain
en quoi c'est une étape cruciale de
cette toute première action justice
fondée sur la loi sur le devoir de
vigilance des multinationales est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer cette loi en
quelques mots alors en quelques mots
donc il s'agit du loin mais qui
s'applique aux grandes entreprises
puisqu'il faut avoir plus de 5000
salariés en france et cette loi
l'obligent finalement les entreprises à
identifier et à prendre des mesures
efficaces pour éviter justement de
porter atteinte de manière grave aux
droits humains au droit de
l'environnement et faire en sorte
finalement que ses activités
les activités propres mais aussi celle
de ses filiales soient en conformité
avec ces réglementations
alors les projets pétroliers de total en
ouganda et en tanzanie quelles
conséquences sur les populations premier
à comprendre mais là ce qu'on a bien vu
dans le rapport publié d'une part ces
deux associations
c'est que il y à un d
l'as mandé population qui est dû au fait
du tracé de l'installation pétrolière et
qui a pour conséquence qu'on doit
déplacer ces populations qui sont sur le
trajet de la patte du 'pipeline' et de
la même façon il va aussi traversé des
zones protégées et de porter atteinte à
la biodiversité et au climat de manière
sûre et donc c'est bien ce que dénonce
et de ces deux associations c'est cette
violation des droits humains et des
droits de l'environnement donc sa tombe
entièrement dans le devoir de vigilance
mais est ce qu'on peut parler de
conséquences directes mais diable ça
malheureusement on peut parler
aujourd'hui
actuellement avec la crise climatique 1
et les enjeux qui sont liées justement
au climat que effectivement les
activités pétrolières de total qui
représente à elle seule 1 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mondiaux a des conséquences qui sont
irrémédiables puisque c'est pas
aujourd'hui l'homme avec l'emballement
du climat quels seront les effets sur le
long terme alors en guyane total s'est
retiré n'est ce pas est ce que c'est une
victoire pour vous c'est temporaire
en fait ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
que c'est un schéma mais c'est une
politique commerciale un de total c'est
à dire que autant ici en ouganda que en
guyane française
on observe justement malheureusement
qu'il y à l'installation de ses projets
pétroliers qui mettent en danger les
populations et l'environnement qui
rendait enfin les populations qui
dépendent directement de l'environnement
pardon ce qu'en guyane française total
avait pour ambition de faire des forages
offshore au large du littoral et que ça
avait pour conséquence directe mettre en
danger l'approvisionnement notamment en
poissons des pêcheries locales
ici on a le même problème en plus avec
un déplacement des populations liés au
tracé du 'pipeline' de ce qui est
intéressant dans cette dans cette
affaire c'est de se poser la question
pourquoi ça arrive encore ce genre de
projet malheureusement post coloniaux et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on laisse faire alors
que justement on devrait pouvoir agir
quand on sait trousser projet et c'est
très intéressant parce que la france
qui s'est dotée justement de cet outil
du devoir de vigilance qui est la seule
à devoir faire respecter justement c'est
ce nouveau cette nouvelle législation
il est maintenant temps que les
tribunaux s'en servent parce que sans
coercition ce en application de ce
devoir de vigilance ça ne vaudra rien ce
ne sera qu'un symbole
alors c'est très important que justement
le tribunal se saisissent de cet outil
et saint serge
évidemment pour sanctionner total dans
cette affaire et pour les entreprises
d'autres pays
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un vide juridique
finalement concernant la non-application
des accords de paris pour les
entreprises
bien sûr et c'est pour ça que c'est
aussi important que la france montre
l'exemple dans cette voie puisque
aujourd'hui malheureusement il n'y a que
les états qui sont tenus par l'accord de
paris or quand on a les multinationales
qui émettent autant que des états comme
c'est le cas de total
il faut que ces états puissent aussi
être tenus de respecter ces accords
sinon effectivement on en vient à
dépasser les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et on voit mal comment on pourrait
s'en sortir mais justement comment faire
en sorte que les entreprises le respecte
dans cette situation ce qu'il faut c'est
que et d'ailleurs ça a été le cas au
début de l'année
total a été mis en demeure puis attaquée
en justice par un conglomérat
d'associations parce que justement dans
le son devoir de vigilance et ne le
reconnaissez pas suffisamment ses
obligations en matière climatique il
faut que total soit maintenant contrat
par la loi par la justice à appliquer
les engagements de l'accord de paris et
vous avec votre association pour
conclure comment est-ce que vous
intervenez alors nous ne faisons pas
d'action en matière de justice
climatique
en revanche nous agissons sur les cas
des causses ide qui pourrait être aussi
un nouvel outil pour justement
contraindre les entreprises à agir
lorsqu'il ya un dommages graves à
l'environnement
ce sera un outil complémentaire en droit
pénal justement qui viendrait renforcer
le droit du commerce qui s'applique
notamment donc
au devoir de vigilance merci beaucoup
marine calme est d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
présidente de l'association wild légal
est resté avec nous dans quelques
instants nous partirons aux états unis
retrouvé notre envoyé spécial stéphanie
de murs rue qui suit pour nous la
campagne présidentielle à seulement sept
jours du scrutin et puis nous parlerons
de la montée brutale de la seconde vague
en europe et ailleurs les gouvernements
durcissent les mesures de restriction
face à la propagation extrêmement rapide
nuque au vide on se retrouve dans 10
minutes sur rt france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi qui ai des condi n'y a
pas d'alternative au sort du québec
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inné gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une à l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
est lié directement au confinement c'est
à dire à la mise en coma artificiel de
l'économie de catastrophe ça veut dire à
côté qatar ce trop fine il ya un
tournant mais on re se remet à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais plaint d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vous ça dépend
quelle valeur on attribue à la mort et à
la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie relève
bien fait mais si on considère que
maintenant il va y avoir des
catastrophes humaines individuelles avec
cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat oral
un débat éthique
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense aux côtés tout au long des
années l'alliance atlantique s'est
investi dans des guerres qui n'étaient
pas toujours réellement en ligne avec
ses objectifs stricts
la situation s'est aggravée avec le
début des attaques contre la frégate
courbet 10 juillet les mots nations
contre la grèce et la présence de dieu à
dist syriens venus 10 livres haut
karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire
mais compte tenu des divergences avec
quelle europe pourront nous le faire
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et et la préparer
il ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire entraîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter 20 à 30% de son
pub pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur nous
expliqué qu'effectivement le réveil va
être compliqué il va être douloureux
il ya eu un moment de très grand
relâchement et nous sommes en train de
payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash vous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
à l'époque il y avait une concurrence
qui était assez violente d'ailleurs
entre les russes et les américains alors
que j'étais destinée à voler avec les
russes mais une opportunité s'est
ouverte de faire partie du deuxième
groupe d'astronautes européens qui m'a
envoyé aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout ça on le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de notre planète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
levitt a été le révélateur des monstres
aux pieds d'argile que nous sommes la
france et je l'aidais elle veut devenir
veut partout mais on n'a pas les moyens
ma critique de ce que nous continuerons
à nier l'évidence c'est à dire nous
continuer à mentir sur la réalité de la
ce pouvoir qui est devenu ump autres dom
est ce que cette france là vous fait
moins peur que celle que vous avez
décrite ses parts à nos membres de la
france objet peur c'est 2 du ca qui
pourrait atteindre pourrait être réservé
à notre beau pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la crise du corona virus s'aggrave en
amérique latine la situation est
effectivement c'est cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon et disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 27 octobre 2020 à une semaine de
l'élection présidentielle plus de 62
millions d'américains ont déjà voté par
anticipation et par correspondance
un mode de fonctionnement à ces
pratiques en cette période de pandémie
pourtant certains craignent des fraudes
ou des ratés pouvant avoir un impact sur
le résultat final du scrutin tous les
jours dans cette émission nous
retrouvons stéphanie de murs eu notre
envoyé spécial aujourd'hui à
philadelphie elle suit pour nous cette
campagne le monde à l'épreuve du virus
et d'une montée brutale de la seconde
vague lé gouvernement durcisse les
mesures de restriction face à la
propagation extrêmement rapide du coc
vide comme en italie ou en espagne
provoquant une colère croissante
couvre-feu confinement fermeture des
bars et restaurants recommandations la
liste s'allonge face à la détresse des
systèmes hospitaliers sous tension
en france la menace terroriste à un
niveau élevé les mesures de vigilance
vont être renforcées notamment lors des
rassemblements de personnes et autour
des lieux de culte comme en témoigne une
note du directeur général de la police
nationale que arte france a pu consulter
une menace alors que les appels à la
haine se multiplient après les appels en
faveur de la liberté d'expression et
l'art publication des caricatures de
mahomet en plein procès des attentats de
janvier 2015 à la menace terroriste qui
met à mal la liberté d'expression à
l'hommage à samuel patty est prévue dans
les écoles lundi prochain sous réserve
de mesures prises face au co vide un
temps pédagogique sera organisée dans
les classes pour reparler des faits et
réaffirmer les principes républicains
comme la liberté d'expression
dorénavant la question d'utiliser les
caricatures controversées comme support
pédagogique se pose alors faut-il
montrer ses caricatures à l'école
peut-on encore le faire ce sera l'objet
de notre face à face
[Musique]
et direction les états unis tout de
suite à sept jours de l'élection
présidentielle nous retrouvons notre
envoyé spécial stéphanie de méru
[Musique]
bonjour stéphanie elle très heureux de
vous retrouver alors vous êtes donc à
philadelphie on le disait en
pennsylvanie et c'est là des états clés
de cette élection
bonjour olivier l'un des swing states
comme on les appelle c'est même je
dirais l'état le plus important sur
lequel il est quasi impossible de
remporter l'élection présidentielle ici
aux etats-unis celui qui l'emportera en
pennsylvanie s'arroge pas moins de vingt
voire au collège électoral pour la
petite anecdote un chiffre parlant il
faut savoir que 20 des parts dont 20 des
25 derniers présidents américains ont
été plébiscités dans cet état de
pennsylvanie
ici les votes par anticipation ont
augmenté de + tenez vous bien de 500 6%
par rapport à 2016
ici vous l'avez dit olivier nous sommes
donc à philadelphie regarder cette files
d'attentes impressionnant derrière moi
elle s'étend sur des centaines de mètres
sur la place magnifique d'ailleurs de ce
city hall 1 philadelphie avait tout à
l'heure un dj un qui mixe et des
danseurs autour on a même vu des
personnes un des votants se faire livrer
des pizzas dans la file d'attenté donc
une joyeuse ambiance ici devant cette
mairie de philadelphie qui votent
on le sait un traditionnellement à
gauche l'avenir en tout cas pour cette
élection nous le dira c'est personnes
qui vont donc rejoindre les plus de 62
millions d'américains qui ont déjà voté
par anticipation et également par
correspondance le vote par
correspondance ici très plébiscité en
raison certainement de la pandémie mais
qui ne plaît guère aux républicains avec
un certain donald trump en tête lui qui
y voit une menace de fraudes massives on
écoute donald trump qui justement était
en meeting dans trois villes de
pennsylvanie r écoutez avec ses
bulletins qui les envoient qu'il les
reçoit que les rapports qu'il le signe
c'est ridicule
c'est la seule façon dont on pourrait
c'est la seule façon dont il pouvait
perdre à mon avis c'est avec une fraude
massive et le président américain qui a
déjà lui-même voter en personne mais pas
par anticipation c'était il ya deux
jours à west palm beach en floride un
vote je cite très sûr bien plus sûr que
celui que l'on fait par courrier a cru
bon d'assurer donald trump a et à
philadelphie où vous vous trouvez le
stéphanie la mort tragique d'un jeune
afro-américain ans tué par la police
pourrait s'inviter dans la campagne mais
absolument ça fait les gros titres ici à
philadelphie cela s'est passé hier
walter ou à la bière c'est son nom avait
27 ans cet afro américain a été tué hier
dans son quartier de queens park à
l'ouest de la ville
les faits se sont déroulés dans l'après
midi l'homme a été abattu par deux
policiers de plusieurs balles sous les
yeux de sa mère selon eric grippe le
porte-parole de la police ici à
philadelphie
walter wallace les menacer avec un
couteau qu'il n'a pas voulu lâcher
malgré les injonctions des agents on
écoutait agrée pas les agents appelés
sur la scène ont vu un homme dans la rue
ils ont immédiatement remarqué le
couteau qu'il brandissait en faisant des
gestes désordonnés les policiers loi
plusieurs reprises sommé de lâcher
larmes
malheureusement il n'a pas obtempéré
après un court laps de temps l'homme a
continué à suivre les agents tout en
grandissant larmes
les officiels ont un nouveau sommet
plusieurs fois de lâcher son arme
malheureusement sans résultat les agents
ont tiré à plusieurs reprises touchant
l'homme et la vidéo de cet événement
tragique a été largement diffusée sur
les réseaux sociaux avant d'être censuré
ce qui a provoqué la colère
de centaines de manifestants quelques
300 d'entre eux ont se sont rassemblés
dans les rues de philadelphie il ya eu
des affrontements très violents avec la
police des vitrines saccagées des
boutiques saccagées 30 policiers ont été
blessés dont plusieurs qui ont été
hospitalisés trente personnes ont été
arrêtées des émeutes on peut le dire
puisque c'est ainsi qu'on les a nommés
ici qui ne sont pas sans rappeler celles
qui se sont produites ici même mais
aussi dans plusieurs villes des états
unis au lendemain de la mort de georges
lefeuvre floride c'était en mai dernier
et qui vous l'avez dit pourrait
certainement pesé dans cette campagne
électorale tant la question raciale
revient souvent en une de l'actualité
ici aux etats unis
merci beaucoup stéphanie de nous faire
vivre au plus près du terrain cette
campagne et on se retrouve très
prochainement bien évidemment pour
continuer à suivre avec vous l'élection
présidentielle américaine est les etats
unis qui ont passé hier la barre des 60
millions de votes déjà recensés dans le
pays à une semaine de l'échéance un vote
par anticipation et correspondante
l'ebit cité on en parlait à l'instant en
cette période de pandémie et qui
pourrait avoir des conséquences
fâcheuses sur le bon déroulé du
dépouillement beaucoup craignent des
fraudes ou des ratés pouvant avoir un
impact sur le résultat
thomas bonnin on est à j moins 7 du
scrutin et il y a d'ores et déjà plus
d'américains qui ont choisi de voter par
anticipation ou par courrier que sur
l'ensemble de l'élection de 2016 à ce
rythme là selon certaines études le
scrutin pourrait rassembler 150 millions
d'électeurs ce qui constituerait un
record depuis 1908 même donald trump lui
même s'est déjà rendu aux urnes c'était
ans en floride il s'y est rendu en
personne et non pas par courrier parce
qu'on sait que c'est un dispositif sur
lequel il a émis de sérieux doutes en
raison de la nouvelle quantités massives
et sans précédent de bulletins de vote
non sollicités qui seront envoyées aux
électeurs ou ailleurs cette année le
résultat des élections du 3 novembre
pourrait ne jamais être déterminé avec
exactitude ce que certains souhaitent
encore un désastre électoral hier
arrêter la folie électorale
certains états sont habitués à ce
système de vote par correspondance mais
ce n'est pas vraiment le cas pour les
états de l'est des états unis dont
certains sont des battleground states
des états clés ou peut basculer
l'élection dans ces états là le
processus est beaucoup moins bien rodée
et donc certains craignent un
engorgement des services postaux ou
encore un taux de rejets importants des
bulletins envoyés par courrier parce que
par exemple il manque une signature
quand on sait que lors de l'élection de
2016 certains états s'était joué à moins
de cent mille voix d'écart il ya
effectivement de quoi être inquiet
ce qui est sûr c'est que la soirée
électorale devrait être plus confuse
qu'à l'accoutumée à moins d'un
raz-de-marée pour l'un ou l'autre des
deux candidats
le suspense devrait s'étaler sur
plusieurs jours et alors le comportement
de joe biden et de deux dalles trump
sera décisif si l'un ou l'autre venait à
revendiquer ou contester des résultats
qui ne sont pas encore définitifs alors
cela pour ajouter le trouble sur l'issue
du scrutin
selon un sondage réalisée par l'ipsos
pour reuters quatre électeurs américains
sur dix qu'ils soient pro trunk ou pro
by dun indiquent qu'ils n'accepteront
pas la défaite de leur candidat
22% des supporters pro by donne et 16%
des supporters pro trump indiquent même
qu'ils se rendront dans la rue pour
manifester
si le résultat n'est pas celui qu'ils
espèrent non je ne suis pas inquiet
notre constitution nous protège de
nombreuses choses et l'une d'entre elles
et un coup d'état bien le fait que
donald trump ne voudrais pas quitter la
maison blanche
j'espère le voir partir le 20 janvier
cela ne me préoccupe pas et je ne suis
pas inquiet l'une des choses
merveilleuses aux états unis c'est que
nous pouvons aller manifester dans la
rue si on le souhaite mais cela ne me
dérange pas qu'ils disent qu'ils iront
manifester si vous me dites que quatre
électeurs sur dix l'accepterons pas le
résultat
cela correspond en fait à la base
électorale de donald trump
ces personnes sont et seront toujours
derrière lui
peut-être qu'il ne l'accepterons pas
mais le résultat de l'élection sera
acceptée par la majorité des gens
ce qui m'inquiète le plus ce sont des
supporters de donald trump qui sont
constitués en milice
armés et qui pense que la réponse à
beaucoup de leurs problèmes et aux
choses avec lesquelles ils ne sont pas
d'accord est une réponse violente celle
confusion autour de l' annonce des
résultats étant plus qu'à redoutée par
les autorités qui ont déployé des forces
de l'ordre en nombre pour encadrer cette
élection dans un pays où les divergences
politiques se sont exprimés dans la rue
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
[Musique]
et on en vient à la situation sanitaire
en europe avec un point sur les derniers
chiffres du corps des individus
coronavirus en france 292 personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital en 24 heures selon
santé publique france le taux de
positivité des tests s'établit désormais
à 18,4 pour cent
au total le nombre de morts s'élève à 35
milles l541 coronavirus donc des
chiffres inquiétants en france mais
c'est aussi le cas dans de nombreux pays
du monde l'organisation mondiale de la
santé appelle à ne pas baisser les bras
son directeur n'assure quand les
responsables agissent rapidement le
virus peut être étouffée à fatick et
sourire la fatigue est réelle mais nous
ne pouvons pas abandonner et vous ne
devons pas abandonner les dirigeants
doivent trouver un équilibre entre la
perturbation des vies et des moyens de
subsistance et la nécessité de protéger
les travailleurs de la santé et les
systèmes de santé alors que les soins
intensifs se remplissent nous devons
devancé ce virus et ensuite nous devons
garder cette avance parfois dans une
course on peut utiliser certaines
tactiques à un moment donné pour
l'instant nous sommes bien en retard sur
ce virus en europe donc pour prendre de
l'avancé
il va falloir accélérer sérieusement nos
actions et peut-être adopté des mesures
beaucoup plus complète pour rattraper et
devancé ce virus et en italie les
nouvelles restrictions ne plaisent pas à
tout le monde des milliers de personnes
ont manifesté hier soir à travers le
pays contre la fermeture des restaurants
et des bars à partir de 18h et de tous
les théâtres cinémas les salles de sport
pendant un mois à des incidents violents
se sont notamment produits à milan et
turin les deux grandes villes du nord la
police anti-émeute a été déployée et a
riposté à coups de gaz lacrymogènes le
1er mai
vous aimez compter doit présenter
aujourd'hui des mesures de soutien aux
secteurs d'activité les plus touchés par
ces mesures de restriction le monde au
creux donc d'une seconde vague qui selon
certains spécialistes pourraient être
plus dur que la première en europe et
ailleurs le gouvernement durcisse des
mesures de restriction le but sauver les
fêtes de fin d'année voyez les
précisions de médiers ski fis
al'approche des fêtes de fin d'année
l'europe s'activent pour freiner
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 en allemagne le
célèbre marché de noël de nuremberg gars
étaient annulés alors que le nombre de
contaminations dans le pays a doublé en
une semaine
le premier ministre italien giuseppe
comté a annoncé la fermeture des bars et
des restaurants à partir de 18h dans le
pays et un couvre-feu nocturne dans
trois régions des mesures qui
permettraient aux italiens d'être plus
sereins d'ici noël
d'après le chef du gouvernement alors
qu'il a averti que les célébrations
festives ne seront pas autorisées en fin
d'année de son côté la slovénie a mis en
place une mesure interdisant les
déplacements entre les deux régions du
pays
à partir de ce mardi si le confinement
partiel est renforcée tout comme les
contrôles aux frontières
moins touché par la crise sanitaire que
la plupart des pays européens
la norvège a tout de même adopté une
nouvelle restriction pour oslo le port
du masque obligatoire et étendu en
belgique les vacances scolaires de la
toussaint ont été prolongé le couvre-feu
a été avancée à 22h pour bruxelles
depuis ce lundi si les activités
sportives et culturelles sont interdites
ce week end l'espagne a prolongé l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'en mai 2021 et
instauré le couvre-feu nocturne sur la
quasi intégralité de son territoire
depuis le 21 octobre l'irlande airs
confiné avec l'interdiction pour ses
habitants de s'éloigner à plus de 5 km
de leur domicile et en russie la
situation sanitaire préoccupe les
autorités le gouvernement a décidé de
mettre en place de nouvelles
restrictions dans le pays le point sur
la situation avec notre correspondant à
moscou antoine gayraud comme dans le
reste de l'europe la russie fait face à
une recrudescence du nombre de cas de
kobe 19 ans réponse l'autorité sanitaire
russe a de nouveau rendu obligatoire le
port du masque dans les endroits fermés
tels que les transports en commun les
taxis parkings et autres ascenseurs
autre mesure alors ce n'est pas encore
le couvre-feu mais on s'en rapproche
l'interdiction d'événements publics et
la fermeture des bars et restaurants
entre 23 heures et 6 heures du matin il
s'agit d'une directive pour l'ensemble
du pays certes mais dont l'application
sera du ressort des autorités régionales
bref pour le kremlin la situation est
préoccupante mais pas dramatique
le président a dit que les chiffres
officiels sont quand même des valeurs
moyennes bien évidemment face à ces
poussées épidémiques sans précédent il y
à des situations de crise ici et là il
nous faut les étudier très soigneusement
pour que ces problèmes ne s'aggrave pas
et ne deviennent pas systémique c'est
autre chose
mais sur le plan conceptuel le système
de santé et bien sûr beaucoup plus près
à ce stress épidémiologique auxquels il
fait face dans le monde entier on viens
de l'entendre les autorités estiment
avoir le contrôle de la situation
elles font confiance au système de santé
et attendent également beaucoup du
vaccin spoutnik v qui va commencer à
être dispensés à la population ces
prochaines semaines
mais surtout moscou cherche à tout prix
à éviter d'imposer à nouveau des mesures
de confinement qui aurait un impact
désastreux sur l'économie la russie donc
et l'europe face à une deuxième vague
brutale le virus circule extrêmement
vite et les mesures se durcissent elle
mais qu'en est-il en afrique alors que
le continent a échappé au pire pronostic
doit-il s'inquiéter aujourd'hui de cette
nouvelle hausse de cas est bien pour en
parler nous sommes avec jean théophile
ben azzouz il est directeur exécutif de
médecins d'afrique
jean théophile bluesy merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
parle aujourd'hui de l'épicentre de
l'épidémie en europe où est-ce qu'on en
est en afrique
il est évident que pour l'afrique
comme vous l'avait dit et plusieurs
personnes l'ont déjà signée
on le constate les chiffres
épidémiologique en afrique l'afrique a
vraiment fait échouer
vous pourrez dire les pronostics qui
était souvent annoncée on a pensé qu'il
doit y avoir des millions de morts
heureusement enfin ne s'est pas passé
comme ça pour l'app store en tout cas
sont très très faible qu'on a très peu
de cadeaux qu'ovide jédir
comparativement à l'europe et à
l'amérique je pense que nous devons
rester quand même très vigilants
alors restez vigilants alors justement
pourquoi vous avez moins de cas sur le
continent africain par exemple sénégal
le niger où le cameroun ont mis en place
des politiques de test est ciblé c'est
cela qui a freiné efficacement la
progression du coronavirus sont pas
seulement parce qu'effectivement les
tests sont arrivés très tardivement en
afrique on était parmi ceux qui
faisaient un plaidoyer pour que les
tests arrivent parce que les médecins
travaillent à l'aveuglette
par contre ce qui a freiné véritablement
le virus je pense à mon sens c'est
l'action rapide des autorités publiques
qui ont effectivement c'était très
difficile
décider rapidement de fermer les
frontières de faire des nouveaux feux et
puis aussi d'installer toutes ces
réactions rapides a permis à mon sens de
freiner les choses n'est pas close pas
seulement cela parce que tout le monde
le dit également
nous avons une population qui est
extrêmement jeunes et ont causé virus
fait plus de mal plus de dégâts auprès
des personnes qui par des commandes
étaient étudiants à l'âge à peu près
supérieur à 65 ans soixante dix ans donc
je pense que le leu leu leu l'afrique
était sur une bonne phase
mais pas seulement flat il ya également
la santé communautaire qui est
extrêmement développée d'afrique a
essuyé énormément d'épidémies notamment
et volaille au choléra le vih et aidera
je pense que l' expertise du continent
être aussi avérée notamment dans la
diffusion des bonnes pratiques
sanitaires un réseau dense de relais
communautaires ont été déployées avec
énormément de messages
la télévision a joué son rôle les
réseaux sociaux tout ceci a poussé à la
comptabilité individuelle est ce que met
en moi les hôpitaux publics sur le
continent africain ont connu des
périodes de saturation de manque de
matériel comment est-ce que ça c'est
géré à ce niveau là bien frileux on
n'était pas préparés on n'était pas
préparé au niveau des hôpitaux parce que
les équipements sont très faibles et
système des systèmes de santé sont
fragiles et même on a constaté sur le
terrain vraiment une désertion des
hôpitaux parce qu'elle est à fond des
patients avaient peur de repas de partir
à l'hôpital et il a fallu faire une
communication ruineux pour les ramener à
l'hôpital non il n'y a pas eu en tout
cas une saturation par rapport à la
copie 19
bien au contraire il ya une tendance à
délaisser les formations sanitaires donc
les gens sont restés chez eux parce que
effectivement il y avait du couvre feu
il y avait une interdiction de sortie et
il n'y avait pas une conscience vraiment
fente auprès des mairies des formations
sanitaires de passe
médecin est ce qu'ils ont été davantage
consulté les médecins libéraux est ce
qu'il ya eu des traitements qui ont été
essayées comment ça s'est passé à ce
niveau là en tout cas il ya très peu de
médecins libéraux comme vous le savez
pourquoi en afrique subsaharienne à rude
épreuve
ils ont été bien sûr très souvent
mobilisés dans l'effort solitaire de
bave pas seulement les médecins mais
aussi des infirmiers et aides soignants
et petit rat aussi les agents de santé
communautaires qui ont été extrêmement
mobilisés ils n'étaient pas des progrès
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas eu un nombre
impressionnant de contamination et
surtout des cas graves
on avait un petit taux de cas
asymptomatiques à 90% quasi donc été
favorable est ce qu'il y avait des
traitements qui ont été utilisés bien
sûr il est vrai que pour la grande
majorité même si la consigne générale
était de ne pas faire le plaidoyer très
officiel de 2006 chloroquine la vitrine
et sinatra
je pense que la plupart des pays
d'afrique a en tout cas des médecins
d'après mes sources en plus utilisé les
toxicos qu'il a su couper à la vitamine
c est parfois donc c'était le traitement
le plus abordable
parce que nous étions aux situations
difficiles personne ne savait comment
aborder la situation et nous avons pris
des protocoles qui ont été un petit peu
annocé au maroc à l'algérie un taux en
france aussi le port sera août et tous
les autres en tout cas les gens ont
travaillé en leur âme et conscience pour
faire face à ce qui était difficile à
organiser
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya tout de même
des inquiétudes quand vous voyez cette
seconde vague en europe notamment est ce
que vous vous préparez un rebond de
l'épidémie en tout cas il ne faut jamais
jamais jamais affluent ça c'est très
très important parce que si on leur fait
la population c'est contre
kif les médecins ne peut pas travailler
dans ces conditions là et d'ailleurs
même si la surmédiatisation et parfois
les fausses informations qui sont
véhiculées saïda stress tout le monde et
je pense que c'est contre productif donc
d'être vigilant bien sûr nous sommes
créés pas rien et nous continuons de
travailler aussi en partenariat entre le
ms avec les institutions publiques pour
faire face à cette seconde vague mais on
le fait en tranquillité parce que c'est
de ne pas affoler les populations c
c'est vraiment un cri d'alarmé que je
lance en afrique on ne pourra pas faire
face aussi à fait assez à cette peur
c'est impossible
du côté de la population globalement il
ya une bonne acceptabilité des mesures
annoncées des restrictions elles sont
bien vécu au il est vrai qu'au dos
c'était difficile parce que confiné des
pays où le système de distribution de
nourriture n'était pas assuré ou les
problèmes des transports n'était pas
assurée pour tout le monde et c'était
très brutal c'est vrai que la population
a énormément souffert mais au fur et à
mesure que nous avons fait de trouver
des solution intermédiaire lui il ya une
vraie acceptabilité on a un exemple d'un
projet qui a été financée d'ailleurs par
l'union européenne au togo où nous avons
monté des cellules des vins et citoyen
où toutes les autorités publiques et guy
compris coutumière se sont levés pour
sensibiliser mais la maison en tout cas
je pense qu'aujourd'hui j'en comprends
qu'il faut faire attention
il est vrai qu'à une lassitude ya une
fatigue les changements ont eu marre de
faire kovy 19 mai en même temps il
il voit avec un regard très clair ce qui
se passe en europe les difficultés que
nous avons ici je pense que les gens se
plaît pas en conséquence et sent prête à
aller plus loin dans l'utilisation fait
en tout cas d d d aider dans la pratique
plutôt d'aider des mesures barrières
merci beaucoup jean queveau fils vont
aussi d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur
exécutif de médecins d'afrique
et restez avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
la menace terroriste en france elle est
élevée
les mesures de vigilance doit être
renforcée notamment lors des
rassemblements de personnes et autour
des lieux de culte
puis nous parlerons de la liberté
d'expression alors qu'un hommage à
samuel patty est prévue dans les écoles
lundi prochain dorénavant la question
d'utiliser les caricatures controversées
comme support pédagogique se pose rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même à
l'époque il y avait une concurrence qui
était assez violente d'ailleurs entre
les russes et les américains alors que
j'étais destinée à voler avec les russes
mais une opportunité s'est ouverte de
faire partie du deuxième groupe
d'astronautes européens du mans voyez
aussitôt à la nasa
et là j'ai une chance extraordinaire de
la nasa m'a entraîné qualifié affecté en
vol comme un des leurs on est loin de la
guerre des étoiles à en est quand même
dans une espèce de con fraternité et de
solidarité l'exploration au sens large
est une activité en coopération
internationale où on se rend service
entre nations qui pourtant au même
moment son sujet d'embargo et de
conflits géopolitiques savoir est ce que
l'homme peut vivre et travailler dans
l'espace est ce qu'il existe de la vie
ailleurs
est ce qu'on pourra un jour s'installer
durablement sur d'autres corps célestes
tout sans le fait en coopération
internationale malgré des tensions
à la surface de notre planète
[Musique]
gaiden ou de la trump a le programme le
plus à même de redresser le pays quand
vous dites à un américain qui va être
taxés plus ils voient rouge
ils pencheront plus tôt pour ceux qui
leur chante une jolie chanson comme quoi
les impôts n'augmenteront pas aux
contours du programme de donald trump
sont quand même assez floue on pour
autant c'est vraiment sur la piste que
les secteurs sg cambon à la veille du
confinement
le taux de chômage est tombé à 3,5
pourtant qu'à tout chômage de plein
emploi je peux vous dire une chose c'est
que le plein emploi
juste avant le coc vide c'était une
blague votre avis sur ce plan de relance
déjà il faut dire rien on est en train
de raser gratis
au bout du compte une facture à régler
baden qui sera sans doute probablement
aussi protectionniste est aussi agressif
sur le plan mondial
ce train
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter en partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française est la france face à une
menace terroriste élevée et constante
dans un télégramme daté du 25 octobre
que rt france a pu consulter
le ministre de l'intérieur signal aux
préfets un risque important d'actes
terroristes sur le territoire une agence
proche d'al qaïda appelle à attaquer le
pays dans le cadre d'un jihad individuel
a parmi les modes opératoires attendent
une voiture bélier et arme blanche elles
et cible les églises et les imam modéré
pour en parler nous sommes avec gilles
sacaze ancien agent du service action de
la dgse
gilles s'agace bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
plusieurs attaques en moins de trois
semaines rue nicolas-appert avec deux
blessés puis l'assassinât de sa mère
pattie le procès des attentats 2015
est ce que tout ça explique en partie le
niveau élevé de menace terroriste
le niveau en réalité il est éveillé et
toujours plus élevées on nous annonce
très élevé puis excessivement élevés
donc il est élevé depuis maintenant une
dizaine d'années il est encore très
élevé pour encore une dizaine d'années
donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on arrête de
se laisser dicter angot le rythme par
pas par l'ennemi en gros ou disons par
la communication de l'ennemi
ce qui fait qu'il ya à nouveau on relève
encore la menace encore une fois je sais
pas si ça a tellement de sens de de le
formuler comme ça parce que en réalité
n'a jamais baissé ce qui fait que là il
ya une excitation supplémentaire c'est
effectivement la communication qui a été
faite ou suit évidemment l'épisode
comprenait les caricatures et de la
réaffirmation pour le coup sûr le saluer
parce qu'il ya longtemps que ce n'était
pas arrivé
la réaffirmation certain nombre de nos
valeurs et de nos libertés par le
président de la république
donc ça mais on est moins les islamistes
mais de toute façon s'ils s'étaient
passés à ce serait autre chose et je
crois que c'est là qu'il faut pas il
faut il faut pas reculer si vous voulez
faut surtout pas le dispositif de
sécurité il est remplacé par des lieux
et on nous parle aussi faut le souligner
parce qu'on demande toujours à nous
parle aussi des imams qui s'inscrivent
dans la danse dans la défense joue dans
l'adoption je dirais que nos valeurs
françaises et républicaine il faut le
souligner parce qu'on me demande en
permanence à nous je pense à l'imam
chalghoumi par exemple qui est qui et
qui sait pas nouveau il s'inscrit dans
ce combat depuis depuis toujours et ils
prennent des risques parce qu'ils sont
là pour le coup ciblé cible est
peut-être plus finalement que que nos
traditionnels je dirais symboles
nationaux
alors on parle d'une agence proche d'al
qaïda qui qui a appelé à ces attaques
qu'est ce qu'on sait de cet ennemi là
aujourd'hui est ce que il est présent
sur le territoire est ce qu on a une
idée est ce qu'on arrive à a finalement
l'identifier alors c'est ennemi là il
était présent il a toujours été présent
sur fait il ya toujour ete énorme faim
depuis maintenant moi je fais des marais
si vous voulez le la révélation est
contestable et difficile a donc en gros
le début de notre dénis si vous voulez à
khaled kelkal en 81 95 si ma mémoire est
bonne vous là on avait pour la première
fois un djihadiste endogène donc depuis
ça n'a fait que croître et on a commencé
à véritablement lutter contre
l'idéologie du terrorisme islamiste faut
rappeler que le terrorisme ici réunis
des olo jai l'est pas au sol on a on a
eu du mal à le nommer et en maintenant
le nommer on le combat depuis peu
finalement de 2 depuis ciel c'était un
nîmois jusqu'à présent on se contentait
de faire les pompiers et de s'en prendre
aux je dirais aux hommes armés mais même
trouvé des hydrocéphale si vous voulez
pour mener des opérations en kalachnikov
on en trouvera toujours la bataille le
fait la guerre se perdra où ce dernier
assure la bataille de l'idéologie et
c'est pour ça quand il était temps comme
mène le faire sur sur cette dimension là
et finalement aussi émis tardivement
alors maintenant quand on commence à
faire il faut surtout pas reculé chaque
recul est si vous voulez quand vous
connaissez un minimum vous avez côtoyé
un minimum la culture islamique et et la
culture arabe parce que finalement c'est
ça ce qu'on le sait s'ils conjuguent et
tout ça si vous voulez chaque reculade
est perçu comme une
une immense faiblesse est
systématiquement suivi d'une nouvelle
charge
donc c'est pas il ya une espèce de
tendance à certains qui se révèle plus
munichois que ce qu'on pouvait
l'imaginer
surtout dans une je pense notamment à
l'extrême gauche française
c'est dramatique alors qu'est-ce qui est
ce qu'il faut mettre en place justement
très très concrètement pour ne pas
reculer face à la menace ajouts sur le
territoire et en même temps aller en
opérations extérieures
comment est-ce qu'il faut aussi prendre
selon vous alors je crois qu en
opérations extérieures
si jamais le combat ait jamais
complètement fini notamment je pense
qu'il faut il faut amener avec nous les
pays arabes sur noter que nous avons
aussi parmi les pays arabes des alliés
dans ce combat il faut les amener avec
nous dans cette fuite à l'extérieur mais
à l'extérieur aujourd'hui le une bonne
partie du travail a été fait puisque nos
armées alors papa isolément bien sûr on
est on est en déshabillé pour ça mais
ont quand même de mise à mal si vous
voulez les bases arrières de l'état
islamique mais d'une façon plus générale
de de tous les groupes islamiques
s'il ya encore des choses à faire je
pense notamment sur le continent
africain et pas que dans la branche
italienne je pense aux au nigeria par
exemple où il n'y a pas grand chose qui
a été fait réellement contre boko haram
c'est peut-être encore une deux une des
derniers gros chantier je dirais mais
qu'il faudrait il faudrait mener mais
globalement les bases arrière
aujourd'hui sont quand même détruite
c'est important c'était important de le
faire c'est important de continuer parce
que ça permet à l'ennemi de former de se
ré articulé d'avoir des bases de repos
des bases d'entraînement etc
donc c'est important et c'est lié si
aujourd'hui l'idéologie a besoin de se
reconstruire ou a besoin d'avoir des
faits d'armes il ya une espèce de fuite
en avant si vous voulez et de mai mais
encore une fois c'est pas ces dernières
menaces et qui qui nous révèle sas et
c'est quelque chose qui est déjà affiché
depuis depuis des mois et finalement
cette crise sanitaire que traverse le
pays au delà l'europe également est ce
que cela change la donne
autant au niveau de la vigilance que des
actions à mener est ce que c'est
davantage favorable aux terroristes est
ce que c'est plus favorable aux
renseignements français quelle est votre
analyse sur ce sujet là alors il ya deux
choses il ya un contexte social
économique et social qui est qui qui se
dégradent et qu'ils ne pourront pas dire
qu'ils s'effondrent mais qui devient
quand même qui est une vraie
préoccupation et qui évidemment ne fait
qu'accentuer les tensions et on le sent
enfin vers l'insécurité dans une
approche plus globale que le terrorisme
la violence la relation entre les gens
qui sont tendues entre les institutions
et les citoyens et c'est évidemment que
la situation sociale et économique ne
fait qu'aggraver les choses
en revanche je pense sincèrement et je
ne m'en dire je ne nie pas la nécessité
du confinement ou des confits demande
sous ses différentes formes de du bien
mal nommée couvre-feu je pense qu'on
devrait parler d'eux plutôt de
confinement sanitaire ou de couvre-feu
vont faire une connotation quasi de
guerre mais bon facilement qui a été
retenu je pense que ça en revanche ça
facilite quand même des choses en terme
de maîtrise du territoire et de sécurité
merci beaucoup
gilles sacaze d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes un
ancien agent du service action de la
dgse
un hommage à samuel patty est donc
prévue dans les écoles lundi prochain
sous réserve bien évidemment de mesures
prises face au co vide un temps
pédagogique sera organisée dans les
classes pour reparler des faits et pour
réaffirmer les principes républicains
comme la liberté on est la liberté
d'expression dorénavant la question
d'utiliser les caricatures controversées
comme support pédagogique et bien elle
se pose
mais pour le président français du culte
musulman ce n'est pas la bonne solution
alors il faut il montrer les caricatures
à l'école pour expliquer aux élèves la
liberté d'expression c'est l'objet tout
de suite de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
rené chiche professeur de philosophie
auteur de la d instruction nationale aux
éditions ovadia bonsoir à vos côtés
yasser louati président du comité
justice et liberté pour tous messieurs
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france rené chiche je me tourne
vers vous vous êtes professeur de
philosophie au retour des vacances dans
le cas où les écoles restent ouvertes
qu'allez-vous proposer à vos élèves est
ce que vous allez venir avec des
caricatures de mahomet dans votre
cartable et bien oui évidemment c'est
une évidence je vais venir à rester
caricature pour une simple raison c'est
que j'ai un collègue qui a été
atrocement assassinés en raison de ses
caricatures
je n'ai pas du tout l'intention en
revanche de montrer ses caricatures pour
les justifier
d'autant plus que personnellement je les
trouve assez laide mais parce que c'est
ça ça ne fait aucun doute dans la mesure
où quelqu un a été tué à cause de ses
dessins il faut absolument que ces
descentes quoi montrer c'est un acte de
résistance l'évident bien entendu je
vais pas me contenter de montrer ses
caricatures leurs sujets abordés par ces
caricatures c'est d'abord c'est le sujet
de la liberté effectivement d'expression
et la liberté d'expression c'est pas
forcément la liberté de dire tout et
n'importe quoi
donc je remettrai les choses en
perspective je pense effectivement qu'il
faut mettre plus en avant que la liberté
d'expression il faut mettre en avant la
liberté de penser et c'est ça qui est en
jeu et c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est un professeur qui a été touchée
hier la outils selon vous est ce que
comme relais si vous vous pensez
finalement que ces caractères tueur sont
un bon support une bonne base pour pour
expliquer la liberté d'expression et le
contexte dans lequel est mort cet
enseignant merci bonsoir donc d'être
déjà il faut quand même qu'on garde une
certaine cohérence donc ce nombre de
caricaturer
moi qui suis un radical cette liberté
dans ce cas là il faudrait pouvoir tout
caricaturer et pas seulement les
personnes qui ne peuvent pas répondre
dans ce cas là si monsieur va chiche
je pense qu'il veut montrer des
caricatures dans ce cas là il faudrait
aussi pouvoir aurait des caricatures
par exemple une photographie d'une
personne qui s'essuie les fesses avec le
drapeau français et qui avait remporté
un concours photo en 2010 hees avait
déclenché une hystérie nationale comme
quoi il faudrait légiférer pour
interdire consommant du drapeau français
dans ce cas là si on continue sur la
caricature continuer dans votre logique
monsieur est invité dieudonné pour qu'il
vienne se fiche des massacres et les
génocides de la shoah donc ce n'est pas
on se moque des personnes qui ne peuvent
pas répondre
ayant dit voici la libre expression en
même temps comment se fait-il qu'en
france on apprend cette liberté avec le
droit d'insulter son voisin son camarade
de classe sont professeurs ou autre nous
en apprend pas cette liberté avec les
personnes qui apportent des idées qui
font avancer le pays pourquoi pas des
personnes qui ont été qui ont été par
exemple
convoqué par le renseignement intérieur
pour leur enquête et leurs révélations
nous qu'on peut pas dire nous défendons
une libre expression dans un sens mais
absolument pas dans l'autre il ya en
même temps je reprends les propos de
jacques chirac qu'on pourra pas accéder
tran islamo gauchiste bien sûr nous
avons tous une libre expression et me
concernant
allez total des seules choses qu'on
devrait interdire les appels à la
violence les appels à la discrimination
ou à la haine point voir maintenant si
voici on nous dit malgré l'expression
c'est j'ajoute et les musulmans dans ce
qu'ils ont de plus cher mais lorsque
mont sacré est insulté je me révolte et
jeudi c'est inacceptable dans ce cas là
on voit bien qu'il ya un deux poids deux
mesures et que l'argument ne tient
absolument pas la route
au t1 un dernier point s'il vous plaît
c'est que mechiche vous révélera après
allez-y merci en même temps c'est qu'il
faut qu'on garde en tête on est en train
de former des jeunes élèves en leur
disant vous voyez ton camarade de classe
musulmans il a ce qui est très cher pour
lui c'est son prophète tel droit de nous
caricaturer et ensuite on eût dit nous
sommes une nation nous sommes unis nous
le
vivre ensemble etc non il ya un moment
j'ai mon droit d'insulter monsieur les
personnes qui parlent avant moi mais pas
responsabilités à ses sensibilités je
m'en excuse ré ré chiche qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ce que vous venez
d'entendre ce que je viens d'entendre
l'autre je voudrais d'abord commencé par
dire que les personnes qui peuvent plus
répondre ce sont celles qui ont été
égorgés décapité donc maintenant les
choses je vous aura toutefois monsieur
le terrorisme international
on l'enlève fox a en des musulmans non
l'as monaco on laisse parler rené d'al
qaïda ce sont des musulmans doit chacun
chacun son tour on laisse parler les
chiffres c'est une contre vérité pas
vous répondre et la frette vous répondra
ensuite
allez-y rené chiche le fait que samuel
pâtisser souvent fait égorger par fou de
l'ariège monde simplement parce qu'ils
avaient été dénoncés par des parents est
complètement hystérique suite suite à un
cours d'éducation morale et civique sûr
sûr sûr sûr la liberté d'expression en
se servant de ses caricatures
ça c'est un fait monsieur on ne peut pas
le nier
donc moi je me place simplement dans ce
contexte je me place dans ce contexte là
dans ce contexte là bon après avoir tué
des journalistes après avoir égorgé un
prêtre après avoir égorgé un enseignant
il ya un minimum de décence à avoir
et cette descente vous ne l'avez pas
vous ne l'avez pas vous qui n'avez pas
la décence vous vous servez restant des
martyrs pour faire passer une idéologie
ne vous avais pas joué s'il vous plaît
allez chiche vous terminez et d'affaires
loyers vous promets vous répondez dans
trente secondes vous dernier mais chez
vous ne savez rien de ce que je vais
dire j'ai dit que j'allais les montrer
ses caricatures parce que c'est c'est
c'est le motif c'est le mobile du crime
et que c'est la moindre des choses que
je dois en tant que professeur de france
à un autre professeur de france qui est
mort dans des conditions atroces ça ça
ne se discute même pas et je soutiens
pour le
complètement le président de la
république qui a dit qu'on continuerait
à montrer des caricatures maintenant
j'ai dit aussi et je le répète que ces
caricatures ne me laisse pas forcément
que je vais pas justifier quoi que ce
soit par l'internaute à ces caricatures
jeu simplement il faut savoir en réalité
il faut savoir respecter dans la
religion ce qui respectable et critiquer
ce qui est critiquable et je dis bien
critiquer et je suis d'accord sur le
fait que des caricatures ne sont pas une
critique
pas plus que les insultes de son
critique les vraies critiques elles ont
été faites par des intellectuels elles
ont été extraits dont des livres et
moraux effectivement au delà de notre
série ak tueur c'est évidemment de faire
lire ces tests est de faire réfléchir
les élèves j'aime me répond ben eliezer
loi dit on dans ce cas-là seriez vous
prêt à caricaturer les services de
renseignement qui ont échoué à protéger
la vie de samuel pâtit bien que nous
avons là la surveillance de masse dans
ce pays
toutes nos communications sont
surveillés par l'état les boîtes noires
et ses allées et m6 catcheur seriez vous
prêt à montrer des caricatures qui se
fiche du renseignement intérieur qui ont
mis en danger la vie de samuel pâtit
deuxièmement dans ce cas là si quelqu'un
vous dit je veux pouvoir à faire
visionner une vidéo de dieudonné
iriez-vous jusque là puisque chacun a
son sacré et que vous dites c'est une
caricature qui nous déplaît je trouve
que j'ai donnée n'est plus marrant du
tout j'assume parfaitement
maintenant si une personne vous dit au
nom de ma liberté de pouvoir me moquer
de ce que les gens vont depuis sacré en
l'occurrence ce que le génocide était
juive au 20e siècle
soyez vous prêt à continuer dans la même
logique mais tout ça la liberté la
liberté ça consiste nos pieds vous le
souhaitez la liberté c'est 6 tu sais
maintenant ce que les musulmans dont
plus cher monsieur vous pouvez pas me
dire le sacré des musulmans ne compte
pas et le sacré des autres est important
événement que c'est heureusement c'est
là qu'on appelle le biais de sa plate le
vivre ensemble et la responsabilité
vis-à-vis des autres il ya serge moati
vous propose en gage que vous concernant
les propos des uns et des autres il y à
aussi à un code un code pénal finalement
qui est là et qui jugent déjà en
fonction du code pénal ce qui n'est plus
que les caricatures ne prévoit pas ne
sont pas pris le maintenon monsieur non
vous n'allez pas me faire le coup du
code pénal et des personnes qui estiment
que les caricatures de dieudonné
sinon des personnes estiment que les
caricatures de dieudonné sur ce que les
juifs ont pu vivre de tragique est
acceptable
j'estime que non j'estime que ça na pas
être diffusée il ya personne peut vous
demander au nom de cette même logique 2
me moquer des autres je voudrais les
regarder
maintenant que diriez vous que dites
vous de mac sans doute un bon français
qui a été moqué en 2010 et les personnes
qui ont fait gagner le concours à cette
photographie ont été licenciées parce
que c'était acceptable mais vous dit
absolument n'importe quoi c'est
effrayant non non non vous feriez bien
de 20h festives ou poser une question à
monsieur vous plaît messieurs on parle
c'est pas la parole
[Musique]
véritablement révoltant vous confondez
tout nu et voulait absolument rien à
voir mais vraiment rien à voir on n'est
pas là en train de de de dire du mal de
la religion n'ont pas remis du coup j'ai
le droit d'insulter ce que les gens je
vous écoute et vous parler à une
personne qui est un radical cette
liberté pour moi devrait l'interdire
je vous dis seulement cette liberté il a
étonné qu'elle vit avec une
responsabilité
elle peut pas être à sens unique je vous
dis seulement si des gens vous disent
vous avez le droit d'insulter mais par
décence ne le fait pas pourquoi continue
à le faire des personnes estiment que se
torcher avec le drapeau français est
inacceptable je le conçois mais des
personnes peux vous dire c'est mon rôle
c'est moral de fer laisse moi donc le
faire une personne a gagné un concours
photo pour s'être torches et des
drapeaux français
les deux personnes ont perdu leur emploi
qu'est-ce que l'on qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant acceptable ou pas rené
schickele vous répondez écoutez
franchement je ne sais même pas de quoi
vous parlez je voudrais simplement dit
elle se sentira sur cette mini série
nationale monsieur en 2010 à serge moati
vous voulez c'est répondre monsieur
chiche s'il vous plaît
franchement ces caricatures d'abord ce
sont ces de l'humour
premièrement c'est de l'humour c'est de
l'extra pas encore celle de l'esprit
mais si vous voulez mais je n'en parle
pas de salle on parle pas de ça monsieur
je vous rappelle qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
s'est fait décapiter vous avez encore la
tête sur vos épaules et c'est très drôle
ça vous paraît très drôle mais moi ça
bouchonne annonce qui est votre bêtise
que samuel faty ce soit décapité et que
des gens comme vous se sert de sa mort
pour faire passer leur idéologie trouve
la descente messieurs c'est jouer avec
ça il y as her louati ses propos bien
évidemment on n'engage que vous on va
clore ici ce débat en tout cas merci à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation directe ur été france merci à
vous rené chiche rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de philosophie auteur de la d
instruction nationale aux éditions
ovadia merci à vous et yasser louati
président du comité justice et liberté
pour tous et c'est la fin de cette
émission mais restez avec nous on va se
retrouver dans quelques minutes à peine
dix minutes pour un point complet sur
l'actualité a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme je monte sur les pentes
appartement on est énervé dans l
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément au loin
de paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui
les dirigent
moi j'adhère mâcon il passera tour de
tracteur et cnooc est en campagne il
faut savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider